Hello and welcome everyone.
This is Active Inference guest stream
number 55.1. It's August 30,
2023. Today we are going to have a
presentation followed by a discussion on
geometric constraints on human brain
function by James Pang and Alex Fornito.
Thank you again for joining. Really
looking forward to the presentation and
the discussion. So please off to you two
to introduce yourself and continue
however you like. Thank you. Well,
thanks very much, Daniel. My name is
Alex Vonita. I'm based in the School of
Psychological Sciences and Turn
Institute for Brain and Mental Health at
Monash University, and James Penn,
who is a research fellow working in the
team. And so the idea today
was that we were going to talk a little
bit about this work. I'll begin by
providing a bit of a historical and
theoretical background and then James
will take over and jump into the
specifics of what we did and what we
found. We're assuming some
basic understanding of neuroscience and
some elements of human brain imaging and
we'll go through a little bit of maths,
but hopefully it'll be enough to give a
picture and if there's any questions
about it afterwards, we'll be happy to
try and answer them. So a
key motivating factor for this work is
really trying to understand how the
structure or anatomy of the brain
constrains its function. And if you look
at a diverse range of systems found
throughout nature, we know that the
structure of the system can change its
dynamics. So, for example, the shape of
a racing car will influence its
aerodynamics and how fast it can go.
The folding patterns of a protein
will influence the other proteins that
it can interact with and have quite
large effects. So here, for example,
we've got example of the hemoglobin
protein in a healthy person and someone
with sickle cell anemia. And this change
in the geometry of the protein leads to
a 20 year difference in life expectancy.
And here we've got the molecular
structures of diamond and graphite. So
both of these materials are made of the
same atoms. They're all purely carbon
atoms. It's just the bonds between them
that are different. And that difference
is sufficient to create quite a
variation in the properties of the
material. So diamond being one of the
hardest substances on Earth and valued
at somewhere between twelve to $90
million per kilo, whereas graphite is
one of the most brittle and only costs
you about $20 per kilo. And so this is
essentially the reason why we don't
propose to people with H two B pencil,
we use diamond rings instead.
Now, the brain is no different. We think
anatomy constraints function, but there
has been a long standing debate about
the specific properties that are the
most relevant and how we should best
conceptualize them. And this can be
traced back to the days of Ramani Kahal
and Camilla Golgi, two people considered
to be some of the founding fathers of
modern neuroscience, golgi developed a
technique for staining neurons that
allowed you to visualize their structure
under the microscope. And Cahal really
perfected that technique and studied the
nervous system in extensive detail and
really laid down the foundations for
what we think about the anatomy of the
brain to this day. Now, both of
these men were recognized for their
efforts in 1906 with a Nobel prize. But
even at the award ceremony, when giving
their lectures, they were in bitter
disagreement. So if you actually look at
the recordings of their lectures,
cahal says, we applied Golgi's method,
and our observations revealed, in my
opinion, the terminal arrangement of the
nerve fibers. Nerve elements possess
reciprocal relationships in continuity,
but not in continuity. So here he's
saying that cells are fundamentally
discrete elements separated in physical
space and that there's a gap between
them at the synapse. The synaptic cleft
and signaling occurs through this gap.
Olga, on the other hand, didn't agree.
He said, while I admire the brilliancy
of the doctrine, which is a worthy
product of the high intellect of my
illustrious Spanish colleague, I cannot
agree with him on some points of an
anatomical nature, which are for the
theory of fundamental importance. I
found myself unable to follow the
current of opinion because I was
confronted by one concrete anatomical
fact. This was the existence of the
formation, which I have called the
diffuse nerve network. And so, for
Golgi, all the cells were continuous.
They form one continuous network. There
was no point of separation between them,
and signaling occurred through this
continuous network.
Now, ultimately,
a growing body of evidence, and you can
see it in Golgi's statements, was
starting to favor Cahal's model. But
really, it was only resolved in the
1940s with the advent of electron
microscopy, where people could actually
resolve synapses and saw that they were
spatially disjoint. And this
ultimately established the neuron
doctrine as the fundamental theory about
how the nerve, the system is organized
at a cellular level. And this basic idea
that we can divide the brain up into
discrete units was then carried through
to different scales, most famously by
Corbinian Broadman, who developed a
parcellation of the cortex based on cyto
architectonic grounds. His idea was that
different parts of the cortex have
different cellular properties, and so
they define these discrete areas that
are functionally specialized in some
way. And certainly this has been
a very influential idea in neuroscience
ever since. But around the same time,
in fact, a couple of years earlier, the
neurologist Alfred Campbell published
his own cytoacyctonic map, and he
agreed that you could identify discrete
boundaries largely in primary zones,
but then in the cortex in between, it
was a lot more difficult to find sharp
outlines or boundaries. And he suggested
that actually the changes were more
gradual or continuous in nature.
Broadman's view became more popular and
certainly became sort of the dominant
theory in neuroscience, even though
subsequent attempts to try to replicate
it were different. And so different
anatomists would parcelate the brain in
different ways, using different
boundaries and so on. But nonetheless,
this kind of congruence
between the discrete model of cahal and
discrete model of Broadman eventually
led to the idea that essentially we can
think about the brain as a multiscale
network where at the cellular level we
can identify discrete cells that are
connected by synapses. Then we can scale
up at the population level at a
mesoscale resolution and identify how
population of cells are linked by
bundles of axons and then all the way
through to the macro scales, which is
what you sort of see when you look at
one of Broadman's maps. You have these
broad, roughly so architectonic areas
connected by white matter bundles.
And in the last two or so
decades we've had the measurement
techniques for characterizing these
networks on a vast scale and there's
been a pretty well established pipeline
for mapping these networks. So the basic
idea is that we have the brain, we
divide it up into these discrete areas
and they act as our network nodes. And
then for every pair of nodes we measure
some aspect of structural or functional
connectivity between them. Functional
connectivity being some aspect of
coupling in activity. And then we can
represent that in the form of a
connectivity matrix. So each row and
column represents a different region and
each element tells you about the type
and strength of connectivity between
areas that can equivalently be
represented as a graph. And then with
that graph representation, we can apply
all sorts of different analytic tools to
understand different aspects about how
the network is connected and organized.
And this basic approach has been used
quite extensively to understand how the
underlying anatomical properties of the
network constrain function. This is one
of my favorite examples. This was a
study of two different worms, c Elegance
and P Pacificus. Both of their nervous
systems in the head have been mapped at
the level of each cell and synapse and
they're actually identical. So they've
got the same type of cells, the same
number of cells, it's just the
connectivity between them that's
different. And that's what you see in
this network projection here that the
topology of the network is different.
And in this study they showed that
changes in the connectivity of just two
hub neurons were sufficient to elicit
a difference in the behavior of the
animals, such that P Pacificus is a
predator of sea elegance. And here you
can see Pacificus eating poor sea
elegance for lunch.
Now, we can't lock humans up in a room
and see who eats who and try to
understand how their anatomy constraints
function in that way. But we can do
things like use MRI to measure
anatomical connectivity and functional
connectivity and correlate the two. And
it's pretty consistent finding that we
generally find there is a correlation
between them. We can run computational
models where we have a structural
network, we simulate the activity. Then
we apply, say, a lesion to that network
and look at the effects on the activity.
And we can show, for example, that if
you lesion a hub area you have quite a
dramatic impact on brain function
compared to if you lesion a more weakly
connected non hub area. Or we could use
clinical studies. We could look at cases
where there are naturally arising
lesions through stroke or some other
form of brain damage and we can
understand the functional impairments
that result. So, for example, in this
case, people with lesions to certain
types of hub areas with diffuse
connectivity showed much more
generalized cognitive impairments than
people with lesions to areas with more
specific patterns of connectivity. So
this is great. This has been really
informative and great for understanding
the role of individual brain regions or
connections in brain function. But it
doesn't really give us a coherent,
unified perspective about how dynamics
emerge from the underlying structure.
It's all a little bit piecemeal. Now,
if we want to develop such a coherent
understanding we can draw some
inspiration from different physics and
engineering where typically the
structural constraints on the dynamics
of a system are studied by understanding
the eigenmodes of the system. Now, the
eigen modes of a system are found by
solving an eigenvalue problem such as
this one. So an eigenvector we can think
of as something that we measure about a
system that doesn't change its direction
if it's subjected to some kind of
transformation. So if that's the case,
then this equality holds. So the idea
here is that PSI is our vector,
something we measure about the system
subjected to some transformation L. And
if PSI is an eigenvector, then the
transformed eigenvector is equal to the
eigenvector just scaled by some value.
So the transformation can scale
the vector, but it doesn't change its
direction. And so if that's the case,
then this scaling factor, lambda, is
what we call an eigenvalue and PSI is an
eigenvector. This kind of equation is
applied to a lot of different systems
and a lot of different contexts. But
when we're studying the eigen modes of a
system, typically our L term
here is an operator called the Laplacian
operator which essentially describes how
smoothly some kind of structural
property of the system varies through an
appropriate spatial embedding. So I'll
come back a little bit to what that
means because we can make different
choices for what we use in L and that
determines the specific anatomical
properties that we prioritize. But for
now, I just want to emphasize that a key
property of these eigenvectors is that
they're orthogonal and so that then we
can use them as a basis set for
reconstructing different activity
patterns that we might see in the
network. So I guess the most
famous example of a basis set that many
people will be familiar with is a
Fourier set. So, for example, here we
have some one dimensional signal, and we
can decompose that signal as a weighted
sum of sine and cosine functions of
varying frequencies. So here you've got
the different functions, different
frequencies, and here you've got some
weighting factors. And we can
reconstruct this signal as a weighted
sum of these functions. In a similar
way, we can extract our Eigen modes of
the brain based on some particular
anatomical property. And we end up with
these spatial patterns here that are
organized again in terms of spatial
frequency or the wavelength of
fluctuation. So here you can see we've
got a very low frequency fluctuation
moving from back to front, top to
bottom, medial, lateral, and then as you
move up, you get these more high
frequency fluctuations. And so then we
can use these patterns to reconstruct
any spatial map that we observe on the
brain. So it could be a map of brain
activity recorded during a particular
task. It could be, say, a map of
cortical thickness variations or gray
matter volume variations. It's
sufficiently general to allow you to
reconstruct any type of map. And so we
can do that just as a weighted sum. So
here Y represents our map, and then we
represent that as a weighted sum of our
modes with the A coefficients
representing the weights.
Sorry, I should emphasize that that
explanation can be a little bit abstract
for people who aren't familiar with
Eigen modes. And it is always a bit of a
challenge to get an intuition. And so
you can do what one of the people in the
team did and asked Chat GPT to explain
eigenmodes to a ten year old. And it
turns out that it does a pretty good
job. I was quite happy with this
explanation, so I thought I'd share it.
So our Chat GPT says, of course, let's
imagine we have a wobbly jiggly bowl of
jelly. When you poke it, it wiggles and
shakes, right? Now, imagine if you poke
the jelly in different spots or with
different amounts of force, each time
you poke it differently, the jelly
wiggles and shakes in a different way.
Eigenmos are like those different ways.
The jelly wiggles and shakes when you
poke it. So essentially, seeing this
video here, the jelly is poked and it
wobbles in a particular way. If you poke
the jelly in a different spot or with a
different amount of force, you'll
trigger a different pattern of
vibration. And so commonly, Eigen modes
are used in the context of systems that
vibrate. And the idea is these Eigen
modes correspond to preferred patterns
of vibration when the system is
perturbed, and those preferred patterns
are just dictated by the structural
properties of that system. We can extend
it more generally and think about it
more as how a system responds to any
type of excitation and how an excitation
spreads through some connected system.
And the Eigen modes correspond to the
preferred patterns of excitation. Again
determined by the physical properties of
the system.
So naturally, given everything we've
been talking about and these ideas that
the brain is a multiscale network, we
need to make a choice about how we
define alloplastian what specific
anatomical properties are we going to
extract our eigen modes from? And so a
natural choice would be to extract them
from brain connectivity. And we can do
this quite in a reasonably
straightforward way. We get some map of
the connections in the brain. We map
connectivity between every pair of
nodes. After we apply some
discretization, we define our discrete
nodes. We map every pair of connections.
We represent that in the form of a
matrix. And then we extract this
quantity here. It's called a graph
Laplacian. The details are not so
important, but that's essentially our l
operator here. And it describes how
smoothly connectivity varies as we move
from node to node in the network. And
when we do that, several studies have
shown that you can use the eigen modes
extracted from this graphaloplassian to
reconstruct kind of classic functional
networks that you record. With
functional MRI, we can reconstruct
different patterns of functional
connectivity between pairs of areas.
You can use it to reconstruct different
eg signals. And people have even shown
that you can make predictions about the
pattern of neurodegeneration that you
see in different forms of dementia. So
this has been really fantastic important
work and a really important proof of
principle that this eigenmode framework
can be used to understand how the
structure of the system constrains its
dynamics. And in each case, the
interpretation is that these dynamical
patterns that we see with fMRI or EEG or
so on, are reflecting excitations of
these underlying eigen modes or the
resonant modes of the anatomy of the
brain. This view very much
aligns with what we would think of as a
classical view of brain organization
that I've just been discussing. So,
following from Cahal and Broadman's
work, the idea is that at lots of
different scales, we can divide the
brain up into discrete areas. They're
connected in some way and it's the
signaling along these connections
between these discrete areas that drives
activity. But there are reasons
to think that, particularly at coarser
scales, so we know at the fundamental
cellular scale, the network is discrete,
but at coarser scales, perhaps a
different set of approximations might be
useful. So if you look at dense
reconstructions of neuronal tissue, so
this is, say, with electron microscopy,
you find that cortical tissue
is extremely dense. It's like a really
rich, thick forest of cells and their
processes. And as we've talked
about, there's been a lot of debate
about where you can actually draw
boundaries between discrete areas and
how valid and reliable that is outside
some kind of classic examples seen in
primary cortex. And if you look more
deeply at the cellular organization of
specific regions, here on the left we've
got the cellular organization and on the
right we've got a myelin stain. You see,
you get these deep penetrating fibers
that are coming in from the white
matter. This is what this kind of
classic graph approach will pick up
because we define our nodes in the
cortex and then we're mapping the
connections that pass through the white
matter. But you can also see that
there's a lot of connectivity that's
moving horizontally or tangential to the
geometry of the cortex. And so these
horizontal connections allow for the
continuous spread of activity. So rather
than activity jumping between discrete
nodes, it can actually spread as a
propagating wave.
And just to emphasize some of
the limitations of the discrete model,
not long after Broadman's work, just a
couple of decades, the renowned
physiologist Lorenzo de Nou was pretty
emphatic about his concerns with the
approach. He said the only really good
cyto architectonic pictures are those of
Campbell, who, let me put in capital
letters, has been the only cyto
architectonist who has described facts
and only facts. The German cyto
architectonist has mixed facts and
theory in such a manner that nobody can
tell where facts ends and theories
begin. So again,
this is just emphasizing the idea that
while we might be able to define
discrete areas at a mesoscopic or
macroscopic resolutions, in some cases,
especially around the borders of primary
sensory or motor areas, for large
swathes of cortex, those distinctions
become a little bit blurry.
So an alternative approach has emerged
out of neural field theory. So neural
field theory has been around for several
decades now and this is a different
approach to thinking about cortical
activity. So the basic idea is that
instead of dividing the brain into
discrete specialized areas or nodes, we
can treat the cortex as a continuous
sheep. And we are actually interested in
trying to capture how patterns of brain
activity propagate through that
continuous sheet. And so this is
something that you can see in diverse
types of electrophysiological
recordings. So this, for example, this
video is of the dynamics of voltage
sensitive dyes recorded in the mouse
brain. And you can see that you observe
these propagating waves of excitation
that move continuously through the
cortex rather than jumping from region
to region as would be implied by a kind
of strongly discrete model.
So a big emphasis in neural field theory
is on describing these wavelike
propagation patterns. And it's been
shown in recent theoretical work that if
we accept that wavelike propagation
drives neuronal activity, then really
the eigen modes that we should be
extracting or prioritizing are those
that are derived from the geometry of
the brain. So our eigenvalue becomes
this problem here where this operator
here is called the LaPlace beltrami
operator and it describes how smoothly
the geometry or the shape or the
curvature of the brain varies through
space. And just to briefly explain why
that's the case, here we've got the
wave equation that's used in some forms
of neural field theory, at least the
divisions that we've been focusing on.
And so the basic idea is that the firing
rate of a given population of neurons B
at location R and T is given by the
Afferent field of incoming populations.
So other populations A. So we've got
other populations providing this
Afferent field of activity that
determines the firing rate of B. And
obviously, we then need to describe what
this afferent field looks like and
that's given by this part of the
equation here. So on the left here,
this set of terms describes how the
field evolves through time. We're not
going to focus on that today over here,
which is what we're interested in,
where we've got how the field is
evolving through space. And so here we
can see our friend, the LaPlace Beltrami
operator, which describes the geometry.
And here we've got the length scale of
axonal connectivity. In this model, we
make a very simple assumption about
connectivity. We assume each point is
connected to its neighbors in a distance
dependent and isotropic way. And that
distance dependence is roughly
exponential. So the idea is that areas
nearby to a given location R will have a
strong influence and that influence
declines roughly exponentially as a
function of distance. And the
speed of that decay is given by this R
term here. You can see that geometry is
firmly embedded in this equation. Now,
I should point out this isn't something
that's just been plucked out of thin
air. This is a damped wave equation
that has been used for centuries to
describe wave dynamics in all sorts of
different media. And so from that
physics, we know very well that the
geometry of the system constrains the
spatial properties of wave propagation.
And you can start from first principles
of neuronal biophysics and derive this
equation.
And given all that work, we know that
the eigen modes of the LaPlace Beltrami
operator actually correspond to the
standing waves of the dynamics. So what
are standing waves? So in this simple
example, we've got two traveling waves
here, a blue and a green. And as they
interact with each other, you get these
patterns of constructive and destructive
interference represented by this red
line here, that cause these very large
amplitude fluctuations that are fixed in
space. So they're not actually traveling
like the original carrier waves,
they're fixed in space. So that's why
they're called standing waves. And
they're a nice example of resonance. So
these fluctuations in
the red trace are much larger in
amplitude than the original carrier
waves. So it's an example of resonance
where we're getting a larger response in
the system than the energy that we put
in. And just to convince you that this
is something real here, for example, we
have a pool of water, a classic wave
system. If you apply vibrations at a
specific point in the pool, you see
these waves that travel out. They hit
the opposite wall, reflect back and
start to interact. And then you see the
emergence of these standing wave
patterns that are fixed in space but
show these very large scale amplitude
fluctuations. Another classic
example is the Cladney plate. So if you
arrange dust particles on a plate and
then you apply some vibration at a
particular frequency, the dust particles
will settle into these complex patterns.
The pattern is determined by the
specific frequency that you apply and
specifically where you apply the
vibration. And the patterns correspond
to the eigen modes of the plate. And
again, those patterns are determined by
the physical properties of the plate
things like its stiffness, its geometry
and so on. This is
a little bit gratuitous, but you can
extend the idea to three dimensions and
you can actually cause the particles to
levitate. Again, in this case, they're
trapped within the nodal lines of sound
waves that are being projected in three
dimensions.
And this does have real world
consequences. So this is a video of the
Tacoma Narrows bridge in the 1940s.
The engineers didn't pay enough
attention to eigen modes. And so on this
particular day, crosswinds hit the
bridge in just the right spots and at
just the right frequencies to excite the
eigen modes of the bridge. So you
triggered these resonant responses and
created these large scale amplitude
fluctuations that ultimately led to the
collapse of the bridge.
So hopefully, that background
has kind of illustrated that there's
sort of two different views of thinking
about which anatomical properties
of the brain might be more important in
constraining dynamics. So on the one
hand, we have the classical kind of
connectome centric view in which we
view the cortex as comprising discrete
areas and dynamics are dominated by node
to node transmission. The connectivity
between areas is topologically complex
and not homogeneous, and we very much
think that that's very important. And so
we prioritize measuring that. We don't
really directly account for the spatial
embedding of the network or its
geometry. We can look at it secondarily,
but it's not baked into the model. And
because we're interested in
connectivity, that means we need to
measure it. So from a practical
perspective, at least, if you're dealing
with neuroimaging data, you need a T one
weighted image to measure brain anatomy
but also diffusion MRI image to be able
to measure brain connectivity.
The other perspective, which is a
geometrically informed perspective that
arises out of neural field theory,
views the cortex as a continuous sheet.
We're not making distinctions between
different areas of the cortex. We think
dynamics are dominated by propagating
waves of excitation, especially at these
mesoscopic and macroscopic scales. We
approximate connectivity between
different points of the cortex as being
homogeneous and distance dependent. So
we know that there is a strong distance
dependent in connectivity. It doesn't
explain everything. So some things are
missed, but we know it's certainly an
important feature. So then the question
is how far we can get with this
approximation. And a nice feature of
this approach is that we are directly
accounting for spatial and geometric
effects, the physical properties of the
brain, which are overlooked by the
connectome approach. A nice practical
benefit of this approach is that because
we approximate connectivity in a simple
way, we don't actually have to measure
it. We can derive our basis set simply
by looking at the geometry of the brain.
And so we only need a T one weighted
scan, which is very standard in MRI
experiments. So hopefully that's
set the scene for thinking about
different anatomical constraints on the
brain and which ones we might want to
prioritize. I'll now hand over to James.
He'll talk about how we went about
testing these different ideas and trying
to understand which constraints might be
more important for dynamics.
Thank you, Alex.
I'm going to focus more on the things
that we found in the paper that we
recently published. I think a lot of you
have the link for it, but let us know
and send us a message if you want to
want us for the link. So basically we
start with we're trying to answer and
test the theory on which modes of the
brain could best describe activity
measured in FMI. So we'll begin by how
do we actually measure these modes. So
geometric modes are based on the T one
weighted image, which is a standard
imaging tool that people use in the
field. And you can extract a model
of the cortical surface here on the
right, and there are robust
pipelines to do so. And you can do that
on a population average sense.
Basically, you get a group template of
the surface, or you can do that on an
individual basis.
On the other hand, connector modes need
deficient MRI and a structural MRI
because you need to kind of align the
two. And then we run a
tractography pipeline, basically finding
connections between regions in the
brain. And then from there you
can construct a vertex level or
even region level connector matrix.
Basically it's a matrix where each
element represents the connection of one
region or one vertex to another region
or another vertex. And you
feed this cortical surface or this
connector matrix in the eigenvalue
problem equations that Alex has
mentioned in the previous slides. And
then how do we test the performance of
these geometric and connector modes?
Basically, we focus a lot on FMI
data. So there
are several open access data sets that
are available. For example, the popular
Human Connector Project, which roughly
has about 1200 participants, but we
focus on 255 participants who are
completely unrelated. There are no twins
and no siblings. And within the
Human Connector Project data set for
each subject, they have what we
call task evoke data. Basically, these
are functional activity
that was recorded whilst each
participant was performing a particular
task. And Hcp has a suite of seven
different tasks, and within each task
several. Different contrasts within it.
And then we also analyze resting state
data. Basically, resting state data is
where the participant is just inside the
scanner and just not doing anything.
And you just scan brain
activity through time and you can
construct a functional connectivity as
well, where each element of this matrix
represents how correlated the activity
is between two regions. We also
analyze data from what we call neural
vault. It's an open access repository of
thousands and thousands of different
maps that people have contributed. And
each map was acquired with distinct
experimental protocols and we
took about 10,000 of those from
Neurovolt. And again,
the level of heterogeneity in the
different tasks is quite remarkable in
the Neurovolt. So we wanted to do
our analysis on quite different tasks to
make sure we are capturing something
really meaningful. So just to remind
yourselves of what we're going to do
next. So basically, Alex already had
mentioned this. You extract, for
example, this spatial map. Say that's
the task evolved map and we decompose
that into different sets of eigen modes.
So these patterns could be the geometric
modes or they could be the connector
modes. And it will be weighted by
a coefficient A, and the weights
represent how each mode is expressed
for that particular map. And you can
truncate the number of modes that you
want to use and then you can reconstruct
back the data
by just taking a linear sum of
the coefficient multiplied by the
geometric or the connector modes. So
what did we find by doing these
analyses? So first I'm going to show you
how the spatial maps look like in terms
of reconstruction. So on the left I'm
showing you the different task develop
special maps, and these are group
average maps for the human connector
project data set. And again, these are
the seven tasks for that data set. And
then we ask, okay, if we use about ten
modes, how would this patient map look
like? And for this result, we're
focusing on the geometric modes. So the
reconstruction looks like this. From
afar they look
quite different, but if you actually
look a bit closely, it already captures
the kind of the large scale core scale
patterns that you can see from the data.
For example, this relational map. You
can clearly see this deemergence of this
big pattern. Now, what happens if we
incorporate more modes into it? So we
increase the number of modes to 100.
And now you can see that the
reconstruction almost looks like
the empirical data, but there are still
subtle differences, especially in the
more localized activity,
for example, here in the arrows. And if
we increase it further, you can see that
we can better capture those isolated
localized patterns just by increasing it
to 200 modes. So you can see that the
modes are actually really an efficient
basis set for task evoke data.
We do the same for resting state data.
We increase the number of modes in here
and compare the functional connectivity
based from the empirical data and the
reconstruction. And we see the same
thing that as you increase the number of
modes to 200, we can capture the
empirical data. And you can do this in a
more systematic way by calculating
how well can we reconstruct the
empirical data just by taking the
correlation of the empirical and the
reconstruction in reconstructed maps as
a function of an increasing number of
modes. And we see that indeed the
reconstruction accuracy increases as we
increase the number of modes. And up to
200, we can get about 85%
to 90% accuracy, which is quite
efficient given that we do the
analysis on a cortical surface
with about 30,000 vertices.
So mathematically, the maximum number of
modes available to us is about 30,000,
and using 200 out of the 30,000, we can
already reconstruct the data quite
efficiently. And then we've
shown that the modes are quite powerful
and efficient in representing the data.
We now test the Hypotheses
or the questions that Alex has laid a
while ago, that are the geometric modes
more parsimonious than the other
anatomical modes? And when I say
anatomical modes, again, we're focusing
on the connector modes, which is based
on the connectivity matrix, but we also
test another anatomical mode based on an
EDR rule. So an EDR rule is the
exponential distance rule, which as Alex
has mentioned a while ago, which is that
because the assumption of neuroflu
theory is that the connections are very
localized and also organized in
a distance dependent way,
specifically, the connection weight
changes exponentially as a function of
distance. So we want to test that
hypothesis on how dominant that
exponential distance effect is.
So for the
details, we just created a synthetic
network based on a simple probability of
connection following an exponential
distance rule with a skating factor
or an exponent alpha, which we matched
from empirical diffusion MRI data. And
again, there's a lot of empirical
evidence of the existence of this
exponential distance rule. So it's not
just a hypothetical theoretical kind
of assumption. We see the effect in
Macaques if you follow the weight as
a function of distance from track
tracing data, and this is in logarithmic
scale, you see this linear curve which
represents an exponential in linear
coordinates. And we see the same with
human diffusion MRI data that the weight
changes as a function of distance in an
exponential distance weight, and even in
other species like mouse rats,
mimosa, and so on and so forth. So this
is a universal property found in a lot
of different species. So this
exponential distance rule connectivity
is actually empirically valid.
So by using these three different
anatomical properties, we can calculate
the modes using the equations that
Alexis mentioned a while ago. And you
can get these geometric modes on the
left, connector modes in the middle,
and the modes from the exponential
distance rule connectivity on the right?
And again, the modes are arranged in
quite a unique way in that the first
couple of modes will represent the low
spatial frequency or patterns with very
long spatial wavelengths. And if you go
further down, you can get these high
special frequency or short special
wavelength patterns.
The basis set that the modes provide can
capture different scales of the data.
So how do these anatomical modes compare
when we now reconstruct the different
FMI data that we have? So, for resting
state functional connectivity, we
compared the three modes, again by
measuring the accuracy as a function of
the number of modes. And you can see
that the geometric modes outperform both
of the connectome and the EDR modes,
but you can see that the EDR modes are
quite close to the geometric modes.
So again, suggesting that the
fundamental effect that the EDR
connectivity does
in empirical data,
it highlights the importance of this
simple but important
exponential distance rule connectivity.
And we can see the same thing by
reconstructing the different task
activation maps that we have. And I'm
showing you here the difference. So it's
the geometric minus the connector and
geometric minus DDR reconstruction
accuracies and red means the geometric
modes are outperforming the other
anatomical modes. So in all the data
sets that we have, the results are quite
consistent. So again, it suggests that
the geometric modes are more
parsimonious than the other anatomical
modes that we have. And then we
go a bit further on, how do we actually
use the concept of these modes in
analyzing FMI
activation maps. So I just kind
of just want to explain a little bit of
what traditional approach we have in
brain map mapping research edge. So for
example, you do an experiment, you
capture the activation map shown here
for a particular task. And I'm showing
you here the kind of the one B version
of that. So the value, the activation
versus the vertex in this cortical
surface. So what traditionally what we
do is to because
we want to highlight people ask, okay,
if a person does a particular task,
which regions of the brain are kind of
driving those the
behavioral performance that we have
whilst performing a particular task. So
what people usually do is to threshold
these maps and and you can set
threshold barely arbitrarily,
and then you can get these clusters of
activity and we then make a
conclusion that these clusters of
activity are the ones kind of driving
the behavioral effects that we
see whilst performing a task. And people
can even go further and hone down
exactly really highly localized regions
if you increase the threshold. But if
you go further back we started from
this whole brain activation map, you can
clearly see that by thresholding you
actually are removing a lot of important
activity patterns that are
sub threshold, but they do exist. So
it's kind of like the analogy.
By doing these thresholding approach,
you're just looking just at the tip of
the iceberg, you're ignoring a lot of
the important properties of the iceberg
that are not seen by the threshold that
you set. So what we can
do is to use the mode approach to
actually look. At.
Look at the properties of all the
activation maps. And here on the left,
I'm showing you here the power of
each mode. So basically the weights that
we obtained from the reconstructions
that we had a while ago. And the
figure on the left shows you the results
that we have on average for the
Human Connector Project data set. And on
the right is for the 10,000 maps from
Neurovolt. So what you can see here
actually is most of the power is
contained within about 50
modes. And if you remember, the modes
represent and each mode represents
a different wavelength and they are
arranged and that the first couple of
modes represent this long spatial
wavelength, spatial structure.
So what this means is that actually in
FMI activation maps, most of the power
is within those long wavelengths, kind
of suggesting that indeed,
even by performing a particular task,
you are actually activating this almost
whole brain so you can
see this almost whole brain activity
that, again, you will miss out if you do
some thresholding effect. And to further
emphasize the importance of these long
wavelength patterns, we did a simple
experiment where we tried to remove,
say, the first couple long wavelength
modes. And that's the solid curve that
you see in here. And by doing so, if we
start removing those long wavelength
modes, the reconstruction accuracy
completely drops, even by just removing
25% of them. But if we just remove the
short wavelength modes so starting from
the right, the effect on the
reconstruction accuracy is not that
significant. So again, alluding to the
fact that these long wavelength modes
are really important and they describe
the important structure found in
activation maps from FMI data.
So again, we've shown how the
modes can explain and represent spatial
activation patterns. What happens with
the dynamics and the
way we can do this is we go back to the
crux of the neural field theory, which
the geometric argument modes were based
from. And Neurofield theory is very
generalized. You can construct different
populations of excitatory inhibitory
neurons and you can even connect the
thyroids and so on and so forth. But the
important bits to remember is that
mirror field theory relies on the idea
that activation propagates through space
as waves. And to simplify
the experiment that we want to do,
because we want to model the activity as
a function of time, we just focus on the
cortex and we simulate the
equation based from the wave model
and we tune the parameter.
But if you look at the equation, there
are only two parameters and we fix one
of them. So basically, the model is only
relying on tuning one free parameter.
And what we did was to compare that with
a more sophisticated neuromass model.
So, neuromass models rely on the
connector. So basically you have regions
in the brain that they are connected and
the connections are based from diffusion
MRI and each region will have its own
dynamical properties so they evolve
through time. So it relies a lot of
on this connection and again, local
dynamics. But it's important to
highlight that this highly sophisticated
model has about 19 parameters and we fix
about 15 adults, but we still need to
kind of tune about four. So in
comparison to the wave model, again,
wave model only has one and what we did
was to how well can it recapitulate
functional connectivity data.
So here I'm showing you an example for
the empirical functional connectivity
that we have and the resulting model
based functional connectivity for both
the wave and the neuromass models.
And we can kind of
quantify how well the model based
functional connectivity results stack
up with respect to the empirical data in
a variety of ways. One can look at how
well does the edge FC. So basically each
element of this matrix compares between
the empirical and the model based data
and you can see that both models are
performing quite similarly. We can
also look at the average connectivity
within each region. So basically you're
taking the average of a row or a column
and you can see that the wave model now
outperforms the neuromus model by a
bit. And you can gain further
because these properties, the first two
properties are based on static FC.
Basically you're kind of averaging the
effects across time. But we also
measured how well two models compare
in capturing dynamical properties
through time. And you see that the wave
model actually outperforms the neural
mass model. And so in summary, for this,
it's just to show that the simplicity of
the wave model can
capture a lot of these properties of
functional data. Again, highlighting the
idea that this wave evolving auto
traveling in space and time in the brain
is probably a good approximation.
We also simulated the effect if
we stimulate, say, the visual cortex.
So we just ping the visual cortex and
allow it to the activity to propagate
through space and time. And this will be
the propagation starts from the visual
cortex and then it goes to the frontal
cortex. And I think I want to highlight
one observation that we found is that we
can see that when we started from the
visual cortex, the activity starts to
separate into two. In the psychology
and neuroscience literature, people have
actually found this effect and they call
it the separation into the dorsal and
ventral stream. And each stream has
important cognitive implications.
But people have tried to explain
this separation by capturing the complex
layer specific activity, individual
cortex. But what this simple experiment
that we have done has shown that maybe
the geometry and the idea of waves
propagating could be sufficient in
obtaining these kind of physiological
effect. And then
we also tried to compare it with how
well does it recapitulate the visual
hierarchy that people have found in
primates. For example, this work in
the last couple of years
where they also did a simulation
where they stimulated the visual cortex.
And what they found was if you follow
regions along the visual hierarchy in
the macaque cortex, you see the activity
patterns are kind of delayed in a
hierarchical way, so they follow the
same kind of relationship
as the visual hierarchy. So we did the
same thing. We compared the activity,
the amplitude of the activity
by matching the regions that people
found in the visual hierarchy of the
maca cortex. And we tried to find the
regions in the human brain and
then we see the same effect. And then
when we compared it to a typical measure
of hierarchy in the neuroimaging
space, by using the intracortical myelin
map, which is just the ratio of t one
and T two, we see the effect that the
time to peak of these activation
patterns well captures
the rank of the intracortical myelin,
again highlighting that. Indeed, what
we're getting is capturing this
hierarchical kind of processing starting
from the visual cortex. And think of
the last result that I want to highlight
is the subcortex,
because again, the brain is not
just the cortex. So what we did was to
also calculate the modes from
subcortical regions and what we did was
to mask these subcortical regions and
perform the same and solve
the same equation using the whole
plastic primary operator. And you can
get these argument modes for the
thalamus triadom and the hippocampus.
And we compared that to what
we call in the field as functional
gradients. Basically, they are
representations, low dimensional
representation of resting state FMI
data. So what
we did was to compare the geometric
modes for the different subcortical
structures and the different
functional gradients based on FMI data.
And you can see that the modes are
almost in perfect correspondence with
the functional gradients and we see the
same effect for the different
structures, again, probably highlighting
the idea that the geometric effects that
we solve in the cortex are much more
dominant in the subcortex, that geometry
really constraints function.
Just to tie things together,
what are the advantages of this approach
that we found? First, it's a more
physical understanding of the
relationship between structure and
function based on ideas in physics
engineering that has been used in the
last century. The vectoring modes are
only based on T one weighted images. So
it's very simple to perform and the
analysis can be done by anyone with
structural T one weighted image. And
hence you can apply it in quite
different experimental contexts in both
humans, other species, health and
disease. And finally, to summarize
things, hopefully we've shown that
geometric modes are indeed more
parsimonious than other anatomical
modes. And this is confirming a lot of
the predictions from theoretical
calculations of near field theory and
highlights the importance of treating
the brain as this really physical system
in correspondence with what people are
doing in physics and engineering. But it
also highlights the idea that the
effects that we see in FMI might be
dominated by the effect of this simple
local and exponential distance rule
connectivity. However,
the contributions of long range
connections are still there, but what
we're highlighting is maybe their
influence may not be observable with the
resolution that we currently have with
FMI data. So it would be interesting to
see and perform these experiments in a
much more highly resolved, say, track
tracing data from other species that
we found that evoked activity is
dominated by these long wavelength
modes, which challenges a lot of the
traditional approach we have in the
Neuroimaging field where we focus a lot
on these focal activations and that
traveling waves shaped by geometry are
sufficient to explain a lot of
physiological phenomena.
They just emerged from the model and we
didn't baked all these physiological
phenomena into the model. And finally
that geometric constraints seem to be
universally exist in both cortex and
subcortex and that we can use one
single approach to study the whole brain
quite nicely. And I just want to add
both Alex and I would like to thank all
the other co authors of the work. It has
been a truly multi institute
collaboration. All the open access data
set that we have used and if people are
interested in doing our analysis,
we have written an open access software
package repository in GitHub. You can
access that in here. So people can
analyze modes in the brain in quite
different contexts that they want to do
and I think that's where we want to end.
Thank you.
Awesome. Well, thank you for the great
presentation. Lot of places to
go. First I'll pass to Dean.
Thank you gentlemen. I first got
wind of this paper through another
individual in the active inference
community and I think I was the one that
may have pounded the table that we might
want to do a guest stream on this and
it's ticked the paper and really brought
it to life. So thank you very much, I
really appreciate it, especially some of
the dynamic images. I think it really
helps in terms of explaining what you
guys were trying
to do your work with and your subject
matter on. So I'll just start with that.
I have some questions later on. But just
first of all, thank you for a fantastic
explanation. Thank you.
When you present this in a neuroscience
setting, what's a common response or
reaction? From the introduction, I could
really tell how careful you were to
speak to the totality and the different
threads in neuroscience. So after all
that set up and all the statistical
analysis that's presented, where does
that put people in terms of their own
understanding of the way that they've
been doing complementary methodologies
or orienting their research questions
that way.
Yeah, I think generally people
are at least we found that people are
quite interested. I guess the approach
is a bit different to how
a neuroscientist would typically think
about the brain but kind of aligns with
how, say a physicist might narrowly
easily start approaching thinking about
or modeling the brain. And so the work
was really trying to bring those two
kind of perspectives together. I think
the reaction is usually kind of this is
really interesting,
how do I make sense of it or what I do
practically,
I guess some
people might kind of split it
artificially into this comparison of odd
geometry versus connectivity which
is probably not the right way to think
about it. The way we like to think about
it is that we're sort of comparing two
different models and each of those
models makes certain approximations and
prioritizes different features.
The approach we put forward in this
paper emphasizes the role of geometry
and it does have connectivity embedded
in that model. It's just a kind of
simplified approximation of
connectivity. This kind of homogeneous
distance dependent journal whereas
typical connectome centric view will try
to capture all the complex connectivity
but we'll ignore also the horizontal
connectivity that really is what drives
activity spreading through the brain
that's completely ignored. And so really
the idea behind this work was to kind of
test in a way between these two
approaches and see which one's
approximations were kind of more useful
in a sense.
Dean, want to add something or I can
make a comment there? No finish this
because then I'm going to ask my
questions about the Jello. Yeah, well,
the statistics was very clear and
it was very interesting how with two
different data sets there were similar
curves with also very different number
of samples. So it was almost like some
of the statistical distributions were
latched onto relatively early and then
that captured the big continent. And a
lot of the connections are local. And
this is, of course, a topic to explore
about the molecular and the mechanistic
electromagnetic basis and whether this
to what extent it represents traveling
propagating electrochemical waves and or
loading heavily on simply diffuse
local connections and even the blurry
line between those two. So it is really
like a question about what is being
captured because even the EDR with the
spread captures a
variance component related to local
abundant, direct, fast acting
connections in some regions and distant
connections maybe over the days.
Distal connections really do matter
as the Jello sets and
things change. But at the exact
timescale that some of these patterns
are happening at your work is
showing new information
and comparison with different ways it's
been looked at.
Yeah, I think one of the things
that it highlighted even probably just
in my head is we've
been focusing a lot on trying to capture
the effects of this complex connectivity
and we ignore all these lateral,
horizontal local diffusing connections.
But what the work has now kind of shown,
it highlighted maybe the issues that we
have with FMI because
truly both of these worlds happen
probably simultaneously. But just the
effects that we're seeing in FMI is
probably not the most efficient way to
capture both worlds or it cannot hung
down the specifics of one world over the
other. In the results that
we're getting is that the effects of
this very localized connectivity
probably dominates a lot of what we
see there FMI. But time will
tell if we improve the ways we capture
brain activity with OpenAI and we can
really kind of particularly focus on the
different aspects of the approximations.
To me, that's the kind of the beauty of
the work. It now highlighted these
effects into the broader audience.
Yeah, everything that we've
presented is really addressing things
that we were at measure with fMRI. So on
pretty coarse spatial and temporal
scales, there's some theoretical work
suggesting that kind of the more complex
aspects of connectivity that can't be
explained by an EDR might play an
important role in supporting dynamic
transitions between different brain
states. But that would happen on a very
rapid scale that could be missed with
fMRI or at least a typically organized
fMRI experiment. And so one thing we're
interested in looking at further is
trying to pick that apart a little bit
and trying to isolate the functional
contributions of those more complicated
connections.
Cool. Dean, can I ask about the metaphor
of the spoon tapping on the cello there?
Metaphorically speaking, that seems like
an external perturbation on something
that can respond to that.
Now, you'll appreciate I'm asking from a
very naive point of view. I'm
comfortable with it. Is there any
difference then in terms of, say,
something that happens interoceptively,
like something that's simply coming from
within system and does that show
up in the same way as when there's a
response to an external stimuli?
Yeah. So the actual underlying model,
a key component that we haven't really
talked about, is that you have
thalamocortical loops and there's a
driving input from the thalamus that
influences the wave activity in the
cortex. And they could be
sensory thalamic nuclei or they could be
interceptive inputs as well. And they
would be expected to drive cortical
activity in different and spatially non
uniform ways.
Really distinguishing between those
different types of inputs, as far as I'm
aware, hasn't been modeled yet. It's all
been kind of at a simple level where you
treat the cortex homogeneously and you
have a single thalamic nucleus. I mean,
some people have started to split them
up, but that would
be that the underlying principle and the
model could be extended in such a way
that you could potentially distinguish
between interreceptive and extra
receptive inputs. Can I ask him one
more? Dan, I just want to add, for
example, the visual cortex experiment
that we perform. It's a really simple
perturbation. Right, but it could
represent different types of
perturbation we just can't particularly
capture at the moment. But it's like an
overlying if we perturb it in a certain
way this will be the effect that we see.
You must have known I was going to ask
next thing because that was the
direction I was going with that visual
cortex example. So from the active
inference community, one of the things
that we're always dealing with is
surprise, say versus sensory
attenuation. And then on the third
vertices, the seeming unawareness
prior to the surprise or the attenuated
state, but still available. And so I'm
kind of curious, when you move away from
the visual can you still have these
sort of same waves going through the
brain because other sensory uptake
is causing that same you get a
surprising feeling, like a sense of
weightlessness perhaps. Right, or you're
an astronaut and that's now something
you become attenuated to.
I know it kind of stuck with the fMRI
but it just seems so the possibilities
in terms of what you guys are opening up
just seems really interesting. Is that
something like the interoceptive thing
where you can see this now having
opening up new areas of inquiry?
Yeah, so I think there's some really
interesting work where people
have looked at recursive
neural nets structured in such a way
that you can get wavelike propagation
between the elements of the network and
have shown that the systems that have
that wavelike propagation, it actually
facilitates their ability to predict
what's happening in, say, a movie. So it
improves their predictive performance
physiologically. It'll have shown that
just with simple visual stimulation you
get these back to front propagations but
there's also front to back propagations
which are presumably encoding the
predictions. And so then the question is
how do the top down predictions and
the bottom up sensory input get
reconciled between the interactions of
these waves? I think these are kind
of really interesting ways forward that
we're still coming to terms with and we
haven't really quite made
sense of what the ways mean
for computation. I know that Peter
Robinson, who's on the slide here has
written a couple of papers talking about
how these fields can relate to
predictions but yeah,
I think this is kind of a very new
exciting area that is worth exploring.
Yeah, one kind of connection there is
like the standing wave that you showed
in the physical water pool. And so
now when we're looking at a solid color
visually and there's some stable non
equilibrium steady state or stable
representation or stable population code
or all these different things which may
not be exhaustive or
incompatible like at all, but there's
some standing wave. Now maybe that is
component number 99, just like principal
component 99. Its amplitude might be
small but there's like some mode
that's ramping up and it's associated
positively or it's ramping down. It's
associated negatively.
And there's some standing pattern
that amidst the pelting of new sensory
observations in like a Bayesian updating
setting, it is remaining the same.
Now the more inertia you have on the
distribution, the more stable it's going
to be. Which is like equivalent to
saying the less attention you pay to
sensory stimuli, the more stable your
priors are going to be. It could be a
prior about perception, could be a prior
about action and there are descending
motor patterns as well.
And all these different modes are being
played like in an apartment building and
there's like different songs but they're
happening in different frequency,
spatial, temporal and frequency bands so
that we can tune in to different songs
like different radio stations, but with
more spatial richness.
It's a total expansion of the palate
that recapitulates certain aspects
of topology and helps us even identify
residuals that are most apt
to be explained that way.
But it also opens up to these
big waves that get filtered out, like by
low pass, potentially filtering in
different data sets so that shorter term
relationships can become more apparent.
But that can be the ripple on the wave
and so end up throwing out a huge amount
just of the sheer information content of
rich, dynamical data sets.
Yeah, really interesting concept,
trying to wrap my head around it.
Yes, it's really cool because again,
we still don't know because what we
found is that for example, in different
task data that we have, not all modes
are equally excited. Certain modes are
excited in quite different ways and we
don't know yet what these combinations
mean. Truly behaviorally,
cognitively.
But yeah, we'll keep working
on it as palace and see what happens.
That's one more quick question. I
appreciate the geometry part of it.
So does
any of this speak also to
sort of the tunneling effects of that
eigenvalue or eigen mode eigenvalue
quantum piece where you can
be riding the surface of this and
appreciating that the parsimonious speak
to that surface effect? Is there
anything about this that also helps us
understand better how something goes
through the wave, like quite literally
across from one slope,
past the crown and onto the other side?
Or is that again something that you guys
weren't really spending a lot of time
on? But I did notice, I pulled up the
paper and I noticed on page eleven you
were talking about some of the ways that
you were analyzing the volumes. So
that's the context that I was curious
about, that sort of tunneling piece to
go along with how we sort of follow the
patterns on the surface.
I'm not quite sure I follow you're
asking. Let me try to
see where it comes as I see it, Dean's,
a quantum tunneling connoisseur post
even and with
the basis set of the sine wave,
it's like imposing this kind of
oscillatory pattern and then you're up,
waiting or downweighting. But is it
possible to use a basis set or is it
possible to detect modes in your
analysis where there's an effect locally
and then there's like a tunnel and
there's like a region that the wave
doesn't appear to pass through?
By the way. Thank you, Daniel.
Stumped. I guess it means on what you
mean by tunneling, right? So, like each
mode, like if you look at the high
frequency modes, they are quite patchy
and so there'll be sort of disjointed
areas of high amplitude and low
amplitude, but they fluctuate in time,
right? Like they're standing waves. And
so they'll kind of alternate up and
down. So in a sense it looks like
there's coupling over long distances,
but that's just due to the standing wave
dynamics, which is just driven by the
interference pattern of the traveling
waves. So I'm
not sure if that's kind of what you were
getting at, but I guess from a
perspective of just if you were just
looking at the standing wave dynamics,
it would look like things in spatially
disjoint locations were kind of coupled
in some way.
It's like one jello, it stays
put where you hit it and it stays put 1
mile away and it oscillates between like
a jump rope or it could be
it somewhere that's also very variable,
then be like the opposite of a jump rope
with one mode. And that's
what's captured in the set of functions
that are then parameterized. So then
when you assemble them or when you
superimpose them, you could get kind
of digitized looking outcome
patterns in terms of the real empirical
correlations and
it's map, not territory. And it's
tempting to interpret these very
literally as with many statistical
tools. When I think, as we've discussed,
there's multiple possible mechanisms and
in your paper and in your work, you've
probably thought of many, many
mechanisms that lend themselves to
unique empirical predictions.
But basis set decomposition
is used like in SPM, which is kind of
like one of the precedents of active
inference. And the work by Karl Frist
and others, it's using basis sets as.
They used. They use it everywhere.
Do you have any closing or
near closing thoughts or where does the
work go? What data sets are salient or
questions or cognitive phenomena or what
are you excited about for your lab and
for the fields.
Your lab?
There's a few different ways that we're
interested in progressing it.
So one is, I guess, trying to reconcile
this purely geometric approach that
makes a very simple approximation with
connectivity, with the actual
connectivity of the brain, and trying to
understand if the
contributions of these kind of complex
connections are not so easily revealed
by a classic fMRI experiment. What are
their contributions to dynamics? And is
there a way of kind of bringing some of
that complex connectivity into the wave
model and trying to get some traction on
that question?
Another aspect is we've done
the simplest thing. We treat all areas
of the cortex as homogeneous, but we
know that's not the case. Areas vary in
terms of the cell density, degree of
myelination, level of synaptic
complexity and density and so on. And so
that, in a sense, could be imagined.
You could imagine that as changing the
effective geometry of the cortex. And so
we're playing around with how do you
introduce that heterogeneity and how
does that change the mode structure and
does that have an impact on your ability
to reconstruct dynamics?
We're then also interested in sort of
taking this forward to leverage
these approaches for thinking about
different ways in which we might be able
to map brain changes in different
disorders or variations across
species and so on. And so kind of like
classical SPM analyses, but making
inference at the modal level and seeing
if that can provide some useful
insights. So there's a few different
strategies.
Any other comments or thoughts? No.
Dean, where do you go after this? Dean?
In your own neuroimaging career?
No. Stop it. I just think it was a very
clear picture. And again, I really
appreciated the paper itself, but
today's presentation sort of brought it
to life and made it. I know that you
guys were really trying to focus on
making sure that you got all of your
formalities in a row, but just the way
you presented it today made it even more
come alive in terms of the mechanisms
that you use to sort of come up with a
clearer picture. That's what I came away
with. So, again, thank you very much.
Cool. Thanks for the invitation. Thank
you. Yeah. We'll look forward to seeing
the continuation of this trajectory.
You're always welcome. Come back. So
thank you both. Thank you. Thanks,
guys. See you.